today's gym oh here let's let's plug you
in gym are you doing okay well there's
the information and welcome Bartlett and
really a great joy to start off the
proceedings for this great conference so
uh I'm gonna start out just talking
about some work that we've been doing in
our lab the past couple of years
addressing issues about pattern
separation and pattern completion these
are very classic theories about the
hippocampus dating back from number of
decades now and they're the kind of
theories that have been gaining lots of
support but we'll hear in the next talk
I think some contrary viewpoints and
that's as being interesting a way to
start off the the meeting but we're
going to talk about some new twists on
some of these classic stories I like to
start out myfox always with this
sentence which comes from the very first
page about keifa needles both the
hippocampus is a cognitive map this
sentence is the one sentence summary of
the cognitive map theory the hippocampus
is the core of a neural memory system
providing an objective spatial framework
within which the items and events of an
organism's experience are located and
interrelated I like to do this sentence
because when you hear about the
cognitive map theory and you hear how
people talk about it even how O'Keefe
and Nadel came to talk about it over the
years
you'll often forget this second part of
the sentence is if it's only about
spatial learning and spatial mapping but
this theory is an explicit theory of
episodic memory they keep it at least as
originally intended it the point of the
spatial framework is not just to support
navigation the spatial learning but this
is the framework that they thought the
brain uses to organize and interrelate
the items and events of experience in a
way that all the different components
experience can be brought down
interrelated onto this consciousness
spatial framework we now think about as
a spatial temporal framework I think my
customer will be talking about that
later on
and-and-and-and binds it together in a
way that it can then be retrieved as an
episodic memory so how does that work
well here's a very very simplified view
of some anatomy that suggests that there
are two different anatomical frameworks
that come together into the campus
they're interconnected with each other
but one framework coming to the medial
frontal cortex we thought we think
belongs to that that provides this
spatial temporal framework and another
pathway coming to the lateral intronic
cortex the hypothesis goes is what
carries the representations of the items
and events of experience I'll bring this
here now cuz this all by background I'm
not going to talk about any of this
honest in the talk I just want to put it
in a bit of a bigger picture of how this
is this is really becoming a consensus
view of what the campus is doing so
people like the late Howard I can bomb
who just passed away this year
unfortunately but he was talking about
along these lines as well as well as
this is something that I think John
Okeefe and Boozman gone and number of
people would really have some agreement
that something along this line is what's
happening to hippocampus and what its
function is on the talk today about this
particular part of the circuit where the
dentate gyrus ca3 get input from both of
these streams and somehow combined
together the information about the items
and events of experience aren't the
spatial temporal framework to create
memories and the classic theories
suggest that dentate gyrus performs a
pattern separation operation whereas ca3
is doing a power and completion
operation and I'll define what we mean
by these specifically but that's one we
talked about today about these two
regions evidence from our lab recently
suggesting like I said some new twists
on this these two stories so what do we
mean by pattern separation it's a term
you see over and over again literature
these days we talk about it based on
David Mars initial idea about expansion
recoding I was part of his cerebellar
theory that he published in 1969 talking
about the granule cell layer in the
cerebellum and then people I think not
and then rolls and Trevor's start
talking about that
hrs granules they are doing very similar
operations the idea is that if you have
an input layer and you want to store it
to minimize interference net memories
the expansionary coding is that you've
got like three out of eight neurons say
as the input pattern if you represent
that now in an output layer of the
larger number of neurons you might have
maybe three out of sixteen around being
active well how does that help memory
well let's assume your next input
pattern is very similar to the first one
but by this expansion recoding
hypothesis you now make this
representation much more different than
this one then the inputs are so that's
what maher suggested is a way of doing
you know pattern separation
orthogonalization and then if you store
these representations with much less
overlap you'll have much fewer errors
and recall and much less interference
you can store many more memories in a
situation like this without interference
so as this idea was applied to dentate
gyrus
it suggests that dentate gyrus granule
cells should fire very sparsely that the
fewer presentations that each neurons
put is part of his population code you
can also store more memory and the
prediction would be that they have very
sharply tuned place fields in the
environment and they should fire rarely
in a limited number environment so it's
a explicit prediction of this idea that
granule cells should fire in a very
sparse manner and there's been a whole
history of recording from granule cells
in the hippocampus and freely moving
animals has actually been plagued by a
problem and the problem is as follows
there are actually two types of
excitatory neurons in the dentate gyrus
you have the granule cell layer here
visiting the campus that's a gyrus ca3
ca1 you blow up this region around the
dentate gyrus granule layer the large
majority of cells huge majority are
adult blowing a granule cells that are
that are born during development but
right here in this region called the
Hylas there are these large cells called
mossy cells that are also excited to our
cell type they feed back onto the
granule layer and actually get feedback
from ca3 and as well as in this
population we have
population of adult born granule cells
during adult neurogenesis and the
question is if you put your recording
actually so your electrode in here you
don't know what are the which of these
cell types you're recording from as well
as population into neurons in here which
I won't even describe so I'm going to
talk to you about our recordings where
I've identified the properties of these
mossy cells these gigantic cells just
below the granule layer and then the
population that we believe of mature
granule cells we're trying to understand
newborn grounds to cell thought we've
got no data on that yet so here are some
studies that Doug good Smith and Kim
Christian did chemist works with Hong
Kong song of our collaborator well we
put animals in four different
environments and had them just do gram
of spatial foraging tasks and these
floors just completely separate rooms in
our lab with different spatial cues
around there and we were very careful to
make sure that we were only looking at
data that came where we knew exactly the
Tetra tip was and that was clearly not
in the granule cell layer and these are
recordings that were done and we
sacrificed the animal either that day or
the very next day so we knew that Tetris
hadn't moved a lot so we we assured we
could be from X to show you the
recording techniques that we recording
cells in a Hylas and this is what
they're firing fields of these cells
looked like they fired his cell one and
fired in all four of these different
rooms and in multiple patches within the
room and here's another example this
self in this recording tip fired also in
all four rooms with very different
spatial firing patterns in each room as
well as a patchy pattern in each room
now it turns out that this was the
pattern of activity that a very
influential paper in 2007 from the Moser
lab suggested was actually granule cells
firing and it really threw the field for
a loop because nobody would call this a
sparse pattern of activity it seemed to
suggest that granule cells were not
doing what we all thought they were for
decades but based on very little real
evidence from the recordings of these
cells and they suggested that this what
granule cells did do notice though that
the firing patterns were different in
each room so it could still be a way of
doing power and separation or
zatia in this in this kind of a code and
in this paper in 2007 suggested that
dense a charge was still doing parent
separation but by a very different
method than mars original idea of
expansion recoding which required the
sparse activity is represented in each
one of these squares I'm a little
confused okay I'm sorry I'm assuming -
my strategy or playstyles okay what's
going on here is each of these each of
these is an activity of one well
isolated single unit one one cell and
the gray squiggles is the trajectory of
the animal running around in each of
these environments ABCD and the that's
the gray Squibbles just the trajectory
the red is the weather rat was one that
still fired
that's one cell missing this so this is
all the activity of us of a single cell
yeah maybe about one-and-a-half meters
the room is about a nine nine feet
square okay
I'm sorry if I please sue me too much
you know people know stop me at any time
okay here is what the details now when
the tetrode is in the granule cell layer
this is what the activity looks like two
different cells here cell two was silent
except for one or two rare spikes in all
four environments cell one fired with a
very nice place cell place field this is
you know this would be indistinguishable
from a classic CA one place sealed that
uh that O'Keefe and Ostrovsky discovered
years ago but was silent in the other
three rooms a little bit of a firing
property here and and but the two
examples I'm showing from here and the
previous slide were actually very
typical examples of what the recordings
were like in the granular layer versus
in the Hylas so this is what we always
thought classically that granule cells
should do very sparse coding the cells
don't fire much at all and make most
environments as silent but when they do
fire they fire in a single field and
only one
for environments so these results are
consistent with the expansion recoding
idea that people have thought for number
of years so here's some summary
statistics on all this if you look at
all of our recordings from the granule
cell layer and Doug we create some I
won't go into details he created some
classifier techniques to try to ice
classify these cells based on a number
of parameters and we're pretty confident
that that these are are accurate but not
100% accurate but what he decided when
he classifies granule cell recording the
number of active rooms how many of those
four rooms did a cell have activity and
a place field so the granular layer most
of them fired in zero rooms they were
just silent throughout the whole
experiment maybe one third of them fired
in one out of the four rooms but none of
them fired in all four rooms in contrast
with the records from the Hylas most of
these cells far in all four rooms
occasionally three - a couple of them
didn't fire at all these actually might
have been misclassified cells we don't
know if you look at how many place
fields there were when the cell was
active did a fart in one spot in that
environment or multiple patchy spots
almost all the granule cells layer
recordings had zero place fields on
occasion they had one where itself in
the hi list had a distribution the mode
was around having two subfields in an
environment every so often one is zero
but sometimes up to four or five or more
so very clearly not awful distinct
populations and activities in these two
cell types now that's still X just sorry
their recordings can we don't really
know exactly what these cells are so
shouting Qian Mo's talk in the lab did
some justice cellular recordings in
freedom moving animals I'm gonna get the
details this is almost like an issue
cell the recording but not quiet but the
idea is we can actually record the cell
with the animals around and then fill it
with neuro biotin to actually label the
cell and find exactly where it was here
is some examples of two granule cells
that she identified as being granule
cells in the granule cell layer each one
of them had a single firing field here
in the center here along the wall here
we can actually see the the the
fluorescence image and she and on all
the granule cells
she had or like this most of them didn't
fire at all but when they did fire they
looked like this and here's her one
really good example of a mossy cell here
in the hi list you can see it's called a
Monte cell because of the the mossy like
appearance to these so-called thorny
excrescences these postsynaptic large
spines and it was one of yourself to
have actually three firing fields so
this is more evidence that really
confirms the idea from the single unit
recording about these two different cell
types so the interim summary is that the
granule cells fire extremely sparsely in
very few environments displaying the
single fields when they're active
consistent with what people have thought
for a number of years about what granule
cells should be doing
mazi cells though this other type of
excitatory cell in the dentate gyrus
they fire promiscuously in many
environments typically displaying
multiple firing fields and each cell can
show what you might call parent
separation in terms of taking
environments and creating very different
presentations of them but they use
distinct mechanisms I'm sorry about
number two are you distinguishing bossy
cells from grid cells mossy cells and
grid cells are completely different so
grid cells are in the media on trying to
cortex and other parts but there are no
grid cells in the hippocampus per se
mossy cells are this cell type that's in
the dentate gyrus okay so by chance when
you look at these they they're patchy
but there is no on average there there's
no hexagonal regularity from them okay
so that's the point inputs from granule
cells stamps onto mossy cells and they
can feed back to granule cells that
Anatomy is not exactly worked out
thought the interesting thing though is
though the synapse and granule cell
aunts in the mossy cell may well be the
most powerful synapse in the brain
so Helen sharkman has data in slices
where she can record a granule cell and
then record mossy cells and she finds
two of them there that are connected to
each other
she reports that every time this granule
cell fires it always produces an action
potential in the mossy cell so it's
really a one-to-one
how many cells is the granule cell
output connected to the axon how many
cells versus Tomasi I know that the
estimates are that a single mossy cell
will get input from around 200 granule
cells I have to think about the other
way I did that I don't have those
numbers on top of my head is it less
what animal so it has less or more less
connects to less cells or more cells
granules I think I'm not sure the
question connections are from a granule
cell to other cells
I don't know we believe although I'm not
sure may not be true but our hypothesis
is that each of these firing fields or
these mossy cells is the single firing
field of one of its grandeur cell inputs
but I don't know the answer exactly your
question but and it's not clear whether
those numbers that are out there are how
accurate they are
okay so basically that's the part of the
story so we think we have you know
rescued the the the classic theories
that not the theories but it's the day
that we thought great ourselves fired
appears to be actually the way they do
fire so I'm gonna move on now to the
second hardest or this pattern
completion part of the story and what I
mean by that is this also coming from
Mars work he called this collateral
effect in his theory of the hippocampus
when you have cells that have these
recurrent Calero system reminiscent of
what's there's a CA three Anatomy into
the campus and the idea is that you have
an input pattern and which drives this
output pattern because the recurring
collateral is that these are modifiable
synapses you can actually modify these
synapses such that the cells can
actually patterns here can do some Auto
Association and do things like pattern
completion or error correction such that
if only a partial input pattern is
presented to the network because these
recurrent collateral system new cells
fire but because of these strengthened
synapses here they actually derive the
activity of the remaining part of the
system of the pattern and that's what's
called pattern completion if I instead
of having two out of four I'd click all
four neurons here but one of them was
was was incorrect like the input was was
wrong similar networks with proper
inhibition and so forth would do the
same thing would actually correct the
input to do the output that would be
expected so the idea is a pattern
completion or generalization error
correction these kind of networks
convenient as far as I'm concerned
they're all pretty much different
manifestations of the same properties
and the thought has always been for
based on this that's that's what ca3
does that's sort of the classic theory
so we've been testing theories like that
over the years and we've done situation
where we have an animal running around
on a circular track with local cues on
the track that are a very salient and
standard distal cues on the wall and if
you look at an overhead view of this
apparatus here's this track with local
cues that the rat just runs around and
circles looking get busy going for
little pieces of food on the track and
on the black curtain are the array of
distal landmarks and after the rat is
very well familiar
environment one day we'll we'll come in
here and we'll do this we'll rotate the
track one way and the queues on the wall
the other way and we want to see other
place fields controlled by the kids on
the track all by the queues on the wall
and and how does the system react to
this rearrangement of the different
landmarks they did this mismatch between
the two different reference frames a
local reference frame and a global
reference frame and here's example we
published in 2004 by inna Lee where we
record CA three simultaneously the CA
one and we represent the date of the
following on the x-axis of these
correlation matrices with plotting the
linearized version of the rats location
in a standard session when the queues
are in the normal location so we just
linearize the track from 0 to 360 and
that's what's represented on the x-axis
the second standard session after a
mismatched session will be rotate the
queues is on this axis and we just do a
correlation so basically we look at all
the population activity of all the cells
recorded and correlate their activity
between a standard one and standard two
so basically the cells are far this
location here fire at the same location
here that's what's represented by this
large correlation band on the main
diagonal cells are fired here fired the
same locations down there too so the
fire here fired the same location here
it's just showing that as expected when
the queues are in the same relationship
the hippocampal spatial representation
in CA 1 and CA 3 are very stable they
have the same same place yield in the
same locations any question about about
these these ok interesting quit was
completely expected by what we know that
place else the interesting question is
how does the cell respond to these human
searches
well if we look at CA 3 first we see
that there's still a band of high
correlation it's not as strong as 10 and
1/2 standard 2 but there's still some
band of high correlation there meaning
though even though we've we've changed
the queues CA 3 is taking this
mismatched input this incorrect inputs
and is still able to retrieve and show a
representation that's very similar to
the m22 the original one but the CA one
without the recurrent collateral system
it gets this input but
has very little correlation in its
output pattern so the difference being
see a 3 and see a one we took as some
evidence in favor of this idea that the
recurrent collaterals into the a3 we're
doing something Valachi a3 take this
corrupted input and actually retrieve
some version of the original input on
the diagonals eh brief the standard ones
tend to is broader than that it would be
the reason for this is that the place
feels in CA 3 tend to be a little bit
larger than in CA 1 so when you do is
correlations because the each field is a
little larger it takes longer longer as
you rotate them before the the
correlations go down to zero no it's
because it's just a property of the
place kills themselves
is there any way to know which way the
Corrections being done whether the
animal is in fact using the distant cues
or the the nearby cues as so in this
case it's this the fact that this band
correlation is slightly below the main
diagonal that means that it's actually
being followed
is being controlled by the local cues on
the track which actually was not what we
expected based on the signal for the
more distant wants to match the local
cues yes or whatever reason and it's
been is conflict in his reference frames
it's choosing to follow coach using the
local frame just like you saw the angle
that you saw with respect to the local
cues or is this still same north-south
orientation so I'm wondering I mean you
have an angle on the ordinate and that
you have rotated the distance the local
cues in two different directions so just
just as had the cells been controlled by
the global cues this correlation band
would have been now on this side of the
diagonal okay and when we record from
medial frontal cortex that's exactly
what happens the medial turn cortex so
it's all controlled by the global cues
I'm not gonna show that data but but we
know that let me get to the other talk
and I'll address that in a way that
maybe without why we interpret that okay
okay great question and and and and I
think we haven't answered to it okay so
that experiment was done recordings in
this part of CA 3 where the recurrent
collateral density is the strongest what
he can Li and Chung Wong in the lab we
will question he was well we actually
know now from an anatomy that there's a
lot of differences along this so-called
transverse axis of CA 3 recurrent
collaterals are stronger here than here
this part is e t3 gets strong an
improvement dentate gyrus and actually
weak or implicit
cortex directly so we wanted to look at
differences along this axis and the
prediction was that pattern completion
though this effect will be stronger out
here where the recurrent collateral
density is stronger than in here and
I'll go by this quickly because we've
seen these graphs before this is our
proximal ca3 this recordings from this
part this is intermediate ca3 this is
distal ca3 in proximal ca3 intermediate
ca3 and distal ca3 well these are the
standard 1 and standard 2 in which we
did a 45 degree mismatch between between
them a 90 degree 135 or 180 different
amounts of mismatch between them but you
can see is when in standing 1 versus
standard 2 in all these cases we see the
nice band of correlation showing that
the the the main representation and the
standard sessions were intact as
expected but what about the standard vs.
mismatch if you look at intermediate CA
3 and distal co 3 first you see these
bands of correlation that are still
there so this is replicating the fact we
had published about in 2004 but in the
proximal CA 3 when it's a small mismatch
45 you still see a banner correlation
it's weaker but as the mismatches get
larger and larger the correlation bands
go away so we've done a lot of
statistics to show you know that this is
this is real and actually this is
exactly what our dentate gyrus
recordings look like so the proximal CA
3 appears to be doing something similar
to what the dentate gyrus is doing and
very different from what intermediate
and distal CA 3 are doing we published
his paper in the same issue of neuron
with the Moser lab who had also very
similar results in a different paradigm
so there seems to be in CA 3 functional
heterogeneity heterogeneity along its
axis broccoli a tree Weiser pattern
separation distal CA 3 seems we biased
for pattern completion
so wrapping up here so here's the last
slide so what's going on here well the
standard suggestions of try synaptic
circuitry from is safe in Toronto or
test goes to dentate gyrus to see a 3 to
see a 1 but it's much more complicated
than that latter amita in frontal cortex
project to all regions mixed input to
density CA 3 but actually segregated
inputs and meaning frontal cortex the
proximal ca1 and lateral to distal ca1
dentate gyrus has stronger inputs
especially from the lower blade to the
proximal ca3 been to the distal CA 3 the
proximal CA three projects
preferentially to distal part of CA 1
whereas distal CA three projects burnout
leads to proximal CA 1 and there's also
a high density recurrent collaterals and
distal and proximal so you put this all
together
it appears that proximal CA 3 is working
more as a unit computationally with the
dentate gyrus bias to do pattern
separation to make two input patterns
more dissimilar and that sends out to
distal CA one which is connected to this
ladder on to run all this items an
events pathway whereas distal CA 3 but
it seems we bias towards a pattern
completion or a generalization error
correction and that actually sends to
proximal CA 1 which is part of this
circuit with NBC where the grid cells
are in the so-called spatial temporal
framework so I think that's really
interesting
anatomy and physiology here suggesting
that the computational models essage
that assume that CA 3 was all the
homogeneous associative Network actually
it's very different that there are
differences in anatomy and connectivity
that suggests that is something about
what this region is processing we once
had in separated input bias whereas this
part is is distal to answer shoutings
question why is CA 1 ignoring the
pattern completed input from CA 3 we
think that's because this is
representing the local queues but we
know from other recordings that this is
representing the global queues and CA 1
is getting a mismatched input and just
under our experimental conditions it's
saying okay
my inputs a mismatch my outputs got a
mismatch because it doesn't have the
kind of circuitry to to do any kind of a
judgment which is right functionally you
can make up a lot of stories about why
the idea is I'm not gonna put too much
evidence that I was ignoring it but it's
just that's what it's doing okay so I'm
just going to finish there start with a
little over time but the questions there
are some interesting differences work I
know that some unpublished yet so I'm
not sure if I'm free to from another lab
so I don't want to say too much about it
but no people are finding gradients of
different cell types and along that axis
as well in different morphology of
pyramidal cells so some very good data
will be coming out soon on that from
another lab I
I can't resist making a comment here
what I really love about what you just
showed is there's such a kind of
mismatch between the way that human
beings would design the Machine and
brain does in the sense that like we'd
like to think of an area like ca3 but in
fact the properties you know varied
along the length of it what does it mean
to make a machine whose property is
continuously varied an information
processing machine I find that very
inventive the connections have gradients
the whole thing is sort of not
rectangular and we don't really have a
way to think about architectures of this
kind of design very well so we're kind
of struggling it's it's really important
to remember this is what's really there
there's this whole dorsal-ventral axis
I'm even talking about where within and
this more data on that that's going on
bud and along the hippocampus so it's a
two-dimensional sheet and things are
mapped on each Mitch and not unlike
neocortex where things are mapped on to
these sheets and some one things going
on here as well and writing it and
that's
[Applause]